what could we do to improve k-12
education in America the best well today
if if you're motivated to learn if you
really really really want to learn this
is a amazing time for everyone because
if you have access to Wikipedia if you
have access to the latest information on
the web there's a new website that I've
just been using with my kids recently
called Khan Academy ka Chan just one guy
doing some unbelievable 15-minute
tutorials there's great college lectures
out on academic earth org so if you're
motivated now you can go to the very
best lectures
speaking of allocation of society's
resources I think you said it on your
campus tour at least at Harvard that the
allocation of IQ points of our society
to Wall Street financial instruments was
higher than it needed to be and that
some of those IQ points should go into
other fields yeah well if you say okay
what portion of society's IQ goes into
studying great teachers and documenting
what those great teachers do and how you
would spread those practices you know
what is effectively the R&D component in
education it's about as close to nil as
you you can imagine yet what's the most
important thing in terms of having a
society that is both got equality of
opportunity and is competitive with
other countries it's education and so
it's it's this mind-blowing
misallocation you know my favorite
vignette is that guy Solomon Khan he was
a hedge fund guy making lots of money
and he quit to do these little web
videos and so we've moved
I'd say about 160 IQ points from the
head fund category into the teaching
many many people in the leveraged way
category so you know that was like that
was a good day the day that his wife let
him quit his job